[Music]
we've had an introductory look at the
epithelial tissues in short now let's
move ahead to know the types of these
epithelial tissues in detail beginning
with the first one which is the simplest
of all the simple squamous epithelium in
this type we find flat cells lying upon
the basement membrane these being
extremely flat or tile like are also
known as basement epithelium the flat
nature itself states their function and
locations such type is mainly used to
transport or precisely to fuse
substances across membranes and also
perform filtration does where do you
think we will find them well think of
the thinnest surfaces in our body yes
the lining of blood capillaries in the
lining of alveoli and also in the inner
lining of mouths well when we talk about
epithelial tissue how can we forget the
skin but wait a second how can we afford
to have such a delicate layer on the
surface that covers the entire body well
it's simple the same squamous epithelium
comes in the form of layers so several
layers one above the other form the
outermost layer of skin which we refer
to as the stratified squamous epithelium
because of multiple layers the
stratified squamous epithelium prevents
wear and tear of the upper surface of
the skin now the next type in our list
is the one where we have tall
pillar-like structures these are
referred to as columnar epithelium due
to the column like appearance that they
have now you may wonder why do we need
such tall cells for covering a surface
well such tall cells help to carry out
absorption or secretion to a good extent
thus according to this function the best
example to locate this type of
epithelium is in the inner lining of
intestine well sometimes a slight
modification is also observed in this
type we fire
tiny hairlike projections called celia
on the surface of these cells now you
may wonder why do these cells need hair
well the basic purpose is to move the
immovable yes whenever you have certain
non motile substances or cells that
these Celia carry out rhythmic movements
that help to move these substances does
this type that is the ciliated columnar
epithelium is far to cover the lining of
the respiratory tract here it helps to
throw out the foreign particles trapped
in mucus which enter the respiratory
tract another location isn't the
fallopian tubes of the female
reproductive system where the Celia
helped to propel the ovum in the forward
direction now these columnar cells are
definitely doing their job well but at
times some substances aggressively pass
through small channels which are lined
by these epithelial cells so then along
with absorption and secretion we need
support to hear the cuboidal epithelial
cells come for a rescue these cuboidal
cells are found lining the kidney
tubules in the thyroid and also in the
ducts of the saliva glands lastly we
also find certain specialized
modifications in these cuboidal cells
they attain the capacity to secrete
important substances in the body these
are simply formed by invert folds in the
cuboidal cells the cells are called as
gland cells and the tissue is called as
glandular epithelium so where will we
find them yes those parts involved in
secretions like the saliva glands mucus
glands gland secreting your wax mammary
glands and also the glands producing
digestive enzymes well with this we come
to the end of the types of epithelial
tissues do you know what connective
tissues are watch our next lesson to
know more
[Music]